[Musique]
une bougie unique qui demande
concentration et précision à valentine
en la décorant c'est avant tout à sa
grand mère qu'elle pense elle lui
offrira à noël la jeune femme aime créer
des choses avec ses mains depuis
plusieurs années elle privilégie les
cadeaux faits maison des cadeaux qui
plaisent à ses proches c'est le fait que
ça a été pensé pour vraiment
spécifiquement et que j'ai vraiment
cherché à faire quelque chose de
personnalisé par exemple en général
j'essaie de rajouter dans initiale ou de
rajouter un petit quelque chose qui qui
leur montrent que c'est vraiment réalisé
pour eux sur sa liste
valentina d'autres présents à fabriquer
elle même comme ce bonnet tricoté pour
sa nièce et l coup elle brode l'auto
entrepreneuse partage sa passion pour
les loisirs créatifs sur un blog sur
lequel créé devient facile j'ai décidé
de partager mon savoir faire pour
motiver les gens à a créé parce que je
trouve que c'est une vraie source de
plaisir qu'on est fiers quand on réalise
des choses par soi même vous avez les
gammes féminines qui sont clipsable et
quand on ne s'est pas créé
on peut se tourner vers l'artisanat
couturière à la balance ion gaël et met
ses lancers comme créatrice pendant les
fêtes
elle réalise la moitié de son chiffre
d'affaires la jeune dijonnaise la firme
il y à une demande pour des produits
faits main locaux on développe de plus
en plus cette sensibilité aux faits main
de pain la réalisation les productions
qui sont plus qualitative mais aussi
plus personnel mais aussi par rapport au
fait que les ventes sont directs et on
évite tout intermédiaire je porte moi
même ça qu'ils étaient faits main donc
en récupération de toiles de jean et les
créateurs ont beaucoup d'idées ça permet
d'utiliser aussi un matériau noble
selon une étude faire soi même c'est se
faire du bien
26% des creative estime que cette
activité renforce la confiance en soi et
permet de développer ses talons